foreign
I don't know should you hey well the
fact that you're calling me suggests
that you probably don't think you should
be correct right I I kind of already yes
really this is this could be the fastest
call in the show history
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show
my voice is cracking because puberty's
here finally my dad said it would come
at some point hey we're so glad you're
here on the greatest mental health and
marriage and parenting podcast it's ever
existed ever existed
um if you want to be on the show
if you want to call and I may not know
the answer but I'll I promise I'll sit
with you
um if you want to be on the show talk
about what's going on in your life and
really like what what can you do next
right because that's really the only
thing we can we can we can change or
effect is what happens what happens next
what's the next thing we do
um give me call
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask
um quick couple housekeeping things
please follow me on the Instagrams gives
me hemorrhoids every time I ask but
please do it please do it please do it
and um don't forget to subscribe
five star review all the all the digital
internety things and you know what high
five if you see me just high five that
seems like subscribing right whatever
let's go to Jessica
in San Antonio or they have the Alamo
which is where they have Peewee Herman's
basement what's up
hey how you doing good you
I'm all right I'm doing all right
excellent excellent usually all right is
code for not very great
wonderful Fair well played okay so
what's up how can I help
hey okay so my question is
um should I marry my fiancee
I don't know should you
well hold on all right before you even
tell me what's what's going on the fact
that you're calling me suggests that you
probably don't think you should be
correct right
kind of already yes I'm on that that uh
I agree right
really
this could be the fastest call in the
show history all right tell me what's up
tell me what's up okay so there's really
a lot to this but I'll try to make it
really short okay
um so we have currently been dating for
about two years
um off and on very tumultuous
um
he lived with me for a period of time
um during that time it was Rocky he
moved out got his own place no problem
great what is tumultuous and rocky mean
those are vague things that could mean
abuse it could mean infidelity it could
mean chaos stealing your money what does
that mean
um
well chaos
um on my end and his
um these
diagnosed uh
schizophrenic and he was not on
medication for a majority of the time
that he was staying with me
um what was your chaos related to
um
depression anxiety okay do either of
y'all do either of y'all use
um so yeah that's what I'm getting to so
um no I do not no I do not currently I
do not do anything nothing smoke drink
nothing okay nothing whatsoever
um
now
I did in the past um so I think that
might have contributed to my mental
problems what was your job of choice
well
um
preferably I would smoke marijuana but I
also did dabble in party drugs such as
like uh Molly I don't know if you're
familiar with that yes very very much so
yeah okay
um and I think that the Molly I really
think contributed to my my mental uh
paranoia uh yeah so were you
hallucinating were you seeing stuff not
saying things but very uh paranoid as
far as like oh this person's following
me
um
okay you know uh my boyfriend's cheating
on me
um
all of that
um so here we are you're engaged after
all that you look at each other and you
say we should get married we
[Music]
we go into the IHOP and you were like
you're the one right over the table all
right so you're engaged now
mm-hmm
so um he he's living on his own
um
he said you know okay we're engaged I
want to come clean
um
usually you come clean before but right
hey you know what here we are they're
here we're here right we're here right
good um he says I want to come clean I I
use meth okay I said okay
um I said that makes a lot of sense
um and he said no it was just one time I
used it when I moved out of your
apartment when I was moving my stuff out
um that was the only time
however before he moved out
um I did go through his phone
um and I found some messages from him to
an unregistered number in his phone
asking for a 20 as a small amount asking
for a small amount and I had confronted
him about it and I said what's up are
you are you using drugs no he said no
I'm not I was getting him for somebody
else okay and it made sense to me
how could that possibly have made sense
to you because he has a very um
self-righteous attitude towards like my
family and my family's addiction problem
um he would talk negatively about
um office the most the most
if you want to know what somebody is
truly dealing with
like deep behind all their masks and
their their seven layers of skin
you want to know what somebody's really
struggling with
find out what they're self-righteous
about
because that's what that's that's where
that's where the dragon sits to cover up
that wound inside someone's obsessed
with your sexual activity or they're
struggling someone's obsessed with I
can't believe addicts are man they are
you know what I'm saying so I I but I
get it so
you think he's been using meth all along
there's some there's some real real some
some significant overlap and
similarities in
um
symptomology right in in the way that
someone who's mapped out or someone
who's struggling with schizophrenia
um presents to the world right very very
similar overlaps
right exactly and that and then that's
another reason why
like the you know the symptoms that I
saw that I could you know that I
would have just attributed to a drug
problem I you know knowing his diagnosis
attributed to just his mental
disorder gotcha
um and let's let's be clear he may have
full-blown schizophrenia if he does Matt
is not helping that problem
right right and or he might not have
schizophrenia at all he might
um just right be messed up and seeing
things or experiencing things and
um have an un unclear understanding of
reality
um yeah so here's Here's my thought the
bigger problem is not that he's used
drugs okay I'm never going to tell
somebody you should never marry somebody
just because of things they've done
their past I think that's a shallow
laneway to look at the world but
I do think there are some things to be
cautious of and I am much more concerned
um
that there's deceit there's dishonesty
here
um
there is hiding and sneaking he's
sneaking around you you're going through
his phone without telling him he's doing
this he's I I just the whole thing feels
really it feels like you are going to an
amusement park and you're signing up for
the ride that ends in a train wreck
that's what it feels like
I I agree
but I will never ever ever tell you
unless there is
um abject abuse to not get married
that's a choice you have to make
right and if any anybody who knows me
knows that I will do what I want that is
I mean that's that's just uh then let me
take him out of the room you are not
ready to get married
because I I'm serious because marriage
is you walking to somebody else this
whole nonsense look dude I I'm convinced
with all my guts the last 25 or 30 years
all of the marriage advice if you will
if you want to call it that was you have
to be a hundred percent whole
before you can marry somebody and what
we have now is an entire generation of
married individuals who are cohabitating
their homes or co-managing their
marriages or co-managing their children
they're co-managing their houses
and they are no more they're just
glorified roommates who hook up less and
less and less and less
and so as as crazy as this sounds the
idea that like I'm just gonna get what I
want to do don't get married because
that's not marriage marriage is taking a
knee and saying I will dedicate my life
to making sure you're you're elevated
and hopefully you marry somebody who has
that same sentiment and you both spend
your lives bringing each other up
right so yeah dude you're not right
you're not ready to get married
you know don't do it and if I'm not
uh if I don't agree with that statement
then I'm I probably still would do it
even though I know it's a train wreck
waiting to happen oh so if somebody says
hey not that I would be not that I
wouldn't be give myself to him
fully and want the best for him and you
know his needs and things like that but
I'm just saying like as far as like if
someone's were to tell me no don't do it
I probably even if I know it's going to
end badly that's probably so like
practically speaking stepping stepping
back
I would want to see
um if you're my if you're my best buddy
you're my sister I would want to see a
you two go to some pre-marital
counseling that includes total
truth-telling
I would want to see a mutual commitment
to sobriety and that's not just like
yeah that means that we're going to go
to both of us are going to go to
meetings every day for the next 60 days
I want to see a mutual commitment to
going after a period of 60 days of
getting sober going back to a
psychiatrist getting another
um mental health eval
and then if I do have schizophrenia or
if I have damaged myself it's like a lot
neurologically through my drug use and I
now need support and resources to be
able to be a functioning member of
society which is great there's no
problem in that
um then I'm gonna get the meds that I
need I I would want to see we are
entering into this thing both of us with
a plan on how we can best be whole and
show up for one another
right
and based on what you've told me that is
a tall order
well actually no marriage counseling was
in the uh plans as far as
um thing but marriage counseling you
can't just go and talk about stuff you
have to go set out a plan and then that
the execution of that plan
is going to be is going to be the
indicator that says yes we are both we
are both on a healing journey together
and we're going to do this
I think you can here's my bigger
question less about did somebody use
meth
more about what is so
devastating inside the body of somebody
that is using math
that this is helping them get through
their day
because because dude alcohol weed what
those things work
that's that's the deal they work cocaine
works
it helps pull your body away from
trauma from pain from hurting
and it disassociates you from yourself
and everybody else it kills you over
time
and so the question is not why are you
using drugs the question is
what is going on inside of you that this
is the best way your body's figure out
how to cope
that's what we're gonna unwind in rehab
that's what we're gonna unwind in AAA is
we're going to unwind with a mental
health professional and
then when we get all the trains back on
the tracks then we're talking hey let's
start making long-term plans together
um and man I think you walk alongside
each other in this you clearly love this
guy and um he loves you
I think y'all make a plan to walk
together but
[Music]
here's the deal if you get married next
weekend I'll cheer you on I'll want the
best for you I'll want it all to work
out super super great I will never root
against you uh but if you're my friend
or my sister I would say hey let's let's
slow the roll a little bit and uh let's
come up with a better plan
I wish you guys the best Jessica thank
you for your call we'll be right back
hey deloney here hey you know a while
back Society went off to rails and
people started to see sleep as like an
annoyance it's something in the way
right just chug another energy drink and
keep hustling and grinding my friends
sleep is not the enemy it's essential to
the way our minds and bodies function
and there are several things you can do
right away to start getting better sleep
first lay off the caffeine especially
after like 10 or 11 A.M and ditch the
screens at least an hour before bed and
I recommend getting a great mattress and
you can get a great mattress from my
friends at dreamcloud I speak from
experience here the right mattress can
make a huge difference in your sleep
quality it's why my family sleeps on
dream Cloud their mattresses are
designed to be soft and cool and
supportive so you can sleep comfortably
all night and right now dream cloud is
offering my listeners 25 off your order
plus 50 in additional savings and 500
199 bucks and accessories when you use
promo code John deloney that's cooling
pillows luxury sheets and a mattress
protector so go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and use code John deloney today
all right let's go to Stephanie and
Grand Rapids Michigan where it's cold
outside what's up Stephanie
um not a whole lot how are you doing
good is it so cold
um it is pretty cold today but you know
what does that mean what does that mean
I think it's I mean it's probably like
30 or something I haven't even looked at
the weather to be honest nope nope it
did got to be 30. uh
Tennessee shuts off they just turn off
everything else this is like this is
like defrosting for us but this is not
cold
it's awesome all right so what's up
Stephanie let's let's let's let's get to
Sullivan
yeah so
um I wanted to see if you could help me
with setting some boundaries for my
alcoholics mom
um I already have a pretty broken
relationship with her but I really only
see her around holidays so we are kind
of coming off of the holidays
um and even with those kind of like not
seen her so much it's still kind of
affects me if she's not sober or things
like that and I just wanted your
perspective
um what to do
so when you when you say tell me about
how it affects you let's go let's start
there um
well like this past
anymore
um and she is in a state of mind I don't
know if it's alcohol or other drugs that
like she cannot come
um and so we do it without her and
that's it's fine I get to see my
brothers and my nieces
but it's still like the next day she'll
call and be like oh I just didn't feel
good yesterday can we reschedule and I'm
upset about it I don't know like so I
want to call out the front first part of
what you said
I think
when you
you all have planned enough events and I
and this is something I know firsthand
okay
uh not with my mom but with other people
that I care about
you plan something firsthand
and you make the plans everybody's in
there's probably some text messages
flying back and forth with some extra
exclamation points or some funny memes
and you do it every year and this is
what kids of of addicts this is for
people who love addicts are people who
struggle with addiction this is people
who are in relationship with people who
struggle with addiction
you allow yourself to believe this is
the year
and you get your hopes up a little bit
and then it the same thing happens and
then you said the magic word it's fine
we all get together and it's fine and
here's let me hear you say it's not
it's not Mom should be there she's not
and so then there's this air of
disappointment and you've probably over
the years gotten really good at taking
disappointment and burying it in the
backyard
and when you do that it grows and it
grows and it grows
and it kind of pulls the whole house
down right it just sinks everything and
then you feel crazy and then you get
pissed at her and it and for me it all
starts and ends with expectations
yeah and I think at this point I I do
I'm to the spot where I kind of expect
her to not be able to come I know but
you kind of hope she does right
yeah do you have little ones do you have
kids
no and that's part of the thing my
husband and I are starting to like
that's gonna be the next phase of our
life and so it's like that would change
things too and so
for me to and so I'm kind of to the spot
do I do I stop trying to plan things
with her because that feels really harsh
um it's not I have one brother who's
done that yeah and then I have another
brother who thinks that's wrong and yeah
um so I think you need a pretty robust
season of letter writing to her with
letters you're never gonna give her
okay here's what I'm really mad about
and maybe for the first time being
honest with yourself and going down that
rabbit hole I'm really like angry
and that anger may be back to when you
were a kid and
also I'm really really sad
like I miss you
like I want my mom
to come to Christmas and buy me a
present and be proud of me
and that's not Madness that's not crazy
that's not entitlement whatever that's
just like that's human a like I want my
mom to give me a Christmas present
and she won't even come because she's
too stoned or too high or too
embarrassed or too shameful or whatever
she's feeling
um I I think it's important to sit in
some of that and you might need to get a
counselor with that you might need to
write those and read them to your
husband and say you can't look at me and
I don't want you know whatever rules you
need to come up with but
um or to get a group of women or go to a
group whatever it is but I think you
need to begin to grieve it because on
the other side of grief is reality
right this is the way this is I I have
managed this kind of thing in my life
with I plan things full-on
and there the plans I make are complete
and anyone is always welcome to be in
addition to those plans
so I set extra seats at my table and
this is metaphorical and and literal I
set extra seats at my table
because somebody coming
extra that I didn't plan for is a bonus
it's a gift
mm-hmm
it's not a the whole I don't build
something on everyone's got to be here
the whole thing Falls over
right and that at some level it's
protection but some some of us just me
dealing with reality
and I think both of your brothers are
handling it on two opposite sides of the
spectrum and both of them are not are
not dealing with reality one of them is
scorched Earth dude that's your mom
right
and the other brother is like it's all
good dude it's all good it's like no she
is a uh person who is struggling to the
point that she's hurting people that she
reports to care about
and then you're there in the middle
right
let me let me give you this you are not
a bad daughter
before keeping yourself and your
marriage safe
you're not a bad daughter for thinking
if I have a baby right now I don't want
my mom around this baby and at the same
time I have to have my mom with me when
I have a baby
yeah both of those things
yeah
it's definitely tough because it is such
a
we only see her so often and it just
yeah it's a repeated
most people in your situation spend a
ton of energy propping up a fantasy that
at one point the sinks hold things going
to turn around it's going to be all good
and if I could just say the right thing
or plan the right thing or get the right
food or get the right meal get the right
gift then it will all be okay and this
isn't on you
yeah and I'm not quite in that spot
where I feel like I'm trying to get it
all perfect so that we can be together
and like pretend that we're a family
because even when she's there it it
doesn't feel like we're a family like
it's obviously broken we all know it's
broken we're not pretending there's an
elephant in the room
it's just
I don't even enjoy that like right like
being it's
and that's I think what I'm struggling
with is like it's hard to be around her
even when she's sober because then it's
still
it's like our relationship I don't know
that's I think what I'm struggling with
is like is our relationship even
something that
I can spend time around her Maybe not
maybe not right now
okay and maybe she's making some choices
right now where she's choosing to not be
in a relationship with you that's
probably a better way to look at it
and to to truly get there
you've got to come up with here's what I
deserve in relationships
here's what I give in relationships
here's what I need
and if you're the child of an alcoholic
you've probably been spending your whole
life trying to run around and solve what
somebody else needs
and you tend to bury your needs because
there's no value to them right who cares
what my needs are I've got my life is
spent meeting somebody else's needs and
maybe for the first time you start to
ask yourself here's what I need
and if she chooses to not meet those
needs
and she's choosing to not be in
relationship with you and then you got
to deal with that because that hurts
but that's the path towards owning
reality this is this is I gotta choose I
gotta choose reality
yeah
and maybe some of the choices of
choosing reality after like what I do
now maybe I'm gonna get a couple of
older women in my local community that
are friends of friends or a buddy of
mine her mom or some people at my church
if you're a church goer and I'm gonna
start making connections because I need
a wise voices in my life right I need
older women in my life who have been
where I'm headed
um and that's just not gonna be from my
mom
yeah and that hurts so bad I know
Stephanie it sounds like you're there
what's the hold up
um
I
I think it's just the
I'm sick of going through the same
things over and over again and like
having the same conversations with my
brothers and just like feel like we get
nowhere like okay so what if you stopped
then how do you like when if I said no
more calling your brothers
no more calling your mom that season's
over from this point before you're gonna
do Thanksgiving and Christmas elsewhere
you and your husband just gonna go do
your own thing you're gonna make it up
as you go you're gonna go up to Traverse
City and y'all just gonna have a fun
weekend and that's gonna be Christmas
that's gonna be Thanksgiving
how do you feel
thinking through that
better the times that I don't have to
try to plan things
her like so what's holding you back from
making that move
um I do have a brother that's a pastor
and so he also looks at that as like
that's not what Jesus would do right
she's broken she's has this mental
illness she's not strong enough me not
reaching out to her hurts her a lot and
I'm like but in the back of my head I'm
like that's the bed she made not me so
I go through that thought a lot of like
I'm hurting her but it's not my fault
um is the
things you've done up till now helping
no
so there's this idea that I'm just an
endless bottomless pit of I just keep
showing up I just keep showing up and
that is not about helping this situation
that's about you feeling better that's
about your brother feeling better
right yeah because yeah if you want to
if you want to get theological for a
second Jesus showed up man to people on
the margins that's where I spent my
whole life is with sitting with people
on the margins that everyone else says
you're not lovable for whatever reason I
believe in that and he also said there's
a moment when you dust your sandals off
and you head to the next town
when your help or support is not welcome
here
and that's a fine line I get that
and
that's why I'm saying one of your
brothers who just cut your mom off I
mean I I couldn't do that some people
could I could do that
but it might be that I'm gonna send a
letter once a month so that my mother
never know never forgets that I love her
and then I'm thinking about her
I'm not in a place where I can call
because calls always devolve into guilt
trips and why didn't you do this and
then I get sick to my stomach and I
throw up and it brings up old stuff so
that's not a healthy move for me
it's not because I'm a coward or weak or
a bad daughter it's because it's just
it's it's a it's a very very toxic it's
not smart
but I will write a letter
every month reminding my mom how much I
love her I'm thinking about her and I
care about you that's it
I do like that idea I think that's very
cute but all that starts from what do I
actually need and maybe part of what you
need Stephanie is I need a relationship
with my mom in some shape form or
fashion
I also need to not get sucked into these
two-hour Vortex phone calls where I hang
up feeling like the worst human who's
ever lived
yeah because my mom can be a vampire
okay so now I've got to come up with a
solution between I can't just abandon my
mom
and I can't continue engaging in our
relationship the way we have so I've got
to do something different
and maybe it's I don't um text Mom I
don't I'm not gonna return text anymore
we're just going to communicate via
letter
and if you have if you have an emergency
please reach out
um
or I will only respond to Mom's text 48
hours after I get it unless it's an
emergency
and that gives me time to process it and
feel it and then I'm not just responding
out of emotion you see what I'm saying
but this is you here here's the magic
word
be curious about it don't rush to say
I'm the worst ever I hate all of it and
be curious about it whoa my mom just
sent me a text and it really got me all
fired up what is it about this text that
is sending me down a rabbit hole
does that make sense and you're gonna
begin to learn a lot about yourself
yeah how long is your mom's alcoholism
as she struggled
uh my whole life okay yeah have you gone
to see somebody
um I have yeah and um my parents got
divorced when I was like nine and that's
when I like went to Al-Anon and got some
help and my dad's gone through a ton of
therapy as well and so
it's definitely something that we've
come together on like
be like my dad's side of the family like
it's a big conversation we we talk it
through and are healthy and cool in our
own ways but yeah my I don't have like a
memory of a sober mom I mean like yeah I
light-heartedly joke that my stepmom is
like my mom but um
it's
yeah it's still but has she served that
role
yeah she has okay maybe you need to
grieve that too and celebrate it at the
same time
yeah I think you're right because that
was supposed to be your mom and thank
God somebody else stepped in to fill
that Gap right yeah that was a huge
blessing like yeah but it's a both end
right that's tough it's tough tough
tough to both hands
um yeah I I think you're right right
there I think you're right right there
um
I just want to give you permission to
put on your oxygen mask first as you
know the little cliche is and that's
going to look different for you in
different seasons and there may be a
season
when you feel strong and robust and I'm
wading into this stuff Mom I'm dragging
you by your pigtails we're going to AAA
I'm not having you may have a season
like that and there may be a season
where I gotta get some space and
separate and I gotta make sure I'm whole
and well and okay
um so that I can do the hard work of
heading back in and again you brought it
up so to get theological for a minute
Jesus continually retreated
to recharge
all right to get prayer and quiet time
and in fact he lamented I don't have a
place to rest man I need to catch up but
like always getting dragged back into
this stuff there comes a moment I gotta
step back and say what do I need to be
whole and well right now so that I can
love as best as I can moving forward
um I would say given all things your
your mom won the lottery with you as a
daughter you're a pretty amazing woman
Stephanie and I appreciate your call
thank you so so so much we'll be right
back
all right let's go to Z in Eugene Oregon
what's up Z
hey Dr John uh
so
um I recently came to find out about you
um I wrote Into the Ramsay show actually
because I was struggling quite a bit
and got uh directed to you and yeah you
got sent over to the B Team sorry man no
no no no no they had very nice things to
say about Chelsea so
um and
started reading your book uh the the on
your past one
and it's been uh first just want to say
you have a very good writing ability I I
write I'm I have no books but you're a
good writer and a lot of the things that
I've read so far really like struck me
I'm as I'm going through I'm
highlighting things and
sharing things with other people where
I'm like is this not true it means the
world to me thank you man yeah it's been
a great book so far and uh
uh chapter two especially really kind of
slapped me in the face a little bit and
I was like yeah okay well I don't feel
quite as crazy now because this is all
true
um
but uh just to give you like a little
bit of background about me
um
I'm 34 today is actually my birthday uh
happy birthday man
thank you it's it's it's been for quite
a while uh birthdays are tough
um
and I I don't know why but like so I was
born on Friday the 13th and now it's
Friday the 13th again and I'm like oh
this is a little strange but
um
they've they've become hard they've been
hard for years and years because uh in
my late teens
I started to have some struggles with
depression and it wasn't anything
really serious at the time but
uh then in like early 20s like 23 or so
it hit really hard to the point where uh
I had to go be put in the hospital and
put on suicide watch and all that kind
of fun stuff
um
and ever since then it's been uh
it's been a very long difficult struggle
it's been about 10 11 years of that
where
uh
it's just like walking through a desert
and and the worst part of all um
so after my first like real battle with
major depression where it was just
sucking the life out of me completely
and nothing felt right and
um
you know you obviously are familiar with
what happens uh it it it felt like a
mental cancer to me is what it felt like
I don't know what cancer feels like but
mentally that's what I felt like I was
going through where I couldn't function
and I
nothing felt right and nothing feels
right
um
double click on that for a second so you
have a
is it that you are going through
experiences and that you
think should feel a certain way and your
body is just not responding with the
right feelings you hold somebody's hands
you kiss them in the words I've heard
often is I feel I feel nothing
like my heart rate doesn't get up and
the adrenaline doesn't pump like it's
like the I'm trying to start the car and
it won't start or like your legs feel
like concrete and you can't get out of
bed and someone could say get up dude
but like I can't move
and and worse than that I mean uh the
past two years especially it's gotten to
the point where like uh you know I've
I've wished for death I've prayed for
death
um
not because I want to die but because I
I don't know that anybody dealing with
the mental illness like truly wants to
die I think they want the pain to stop
that's right that's 100 so
yeah and and I mean I don't want to say
good things have come out of this but
some I guess because uh
in the early days of this you know I did
drink and I did do some some foolishness
and now I'm very careful not to do that
stuff because it just makes it worse for
me and probably for everybody but so I
don't do that I don't do drugs or
anything
um okay so let me
this is gonna sound like a strange
question
but alcohol worked right
even definitely gave me something there
you go
so my question right now is like I'm
really really proud of you for stepping
away because you're doing stuff that you
knew in the short term and the long term
were no good
they made you less versions of yourself
but often
the I'm trying to think it's I don't
know if it's
Adler
one of the famous psychologists said
something profound that has stuck with
me they said I thought that if I took
away my clients depression and anxiety I
would make them whole
and what I found is when I took away
their depression anxiety I made them
empty
and there was nothing to backfill it
and so you've stopped doing these tough
things
what have you done in their place
um I definitely at the time I was
drinking and doing dumb stuff I was
um
I grew up religious and I definitely
wasn't for a long time I definitely had
some
anger there I've been trying to turn
that around for several years just
because hold on
stop going to war with Z I like you
can I tell you that
yeah
I like you
like I think you would be my friend
hopefully and I I
I've been through dude I've been through
profound Seasons years at a time when I
would say functioning atheist I've been
a functioning atheist in religious
environments where my job like part of
my job was my belief structure
right and there's a difference between
going to war with myself
and it's like going outside and staring
at the sky and demanding that it looked
green and it's like it does it just
looks blue and I can squeeze my hands
real tight I can bang my head against
the hood of my car it's right now it
looks green man I mean this looks blue I
can't make it look green and so there
was that switch for me that was I'm just
gonna quit going to war with myself
I I will have people in my life that
hold my actions accountable when it
comes to belief and it comes to feelings
mind systems are just not don't work
that great sometimes and so I'm gonna be
I'm gonna hold them really really
loosely
and I know some religious structures
would I don't know your background with
that
the the looser you hold it the more they
tell you you're failing and that you're
hated and that you're not loved and I
want to tell you that's nonsense and
it's bull crap
yeah it's not true
okay well and I've been I've been lucky
to have good people in my life who
awesome never made me feel like I was uh
what would you call it like
defective in that regard or that I
wasn't trying hard enough awesome
um they've just been like you know just
keep moving forward uh you know it
doesn't matter like if you have
a lot of faith or a little faith just
hold on to what you have and and don't
let go of it and sometimes sometimes
there's going through the motions I'm
gonna do the right things even though I
don't know what I'm doing right so some
of that too right yeah but that can feel
really feel really Hollow
yes yeah
and you know the people who have known
me the longest they can tell that they
can perceive that
um
but
definitely
um so bring me to right now where are
you right now
well the thing I was going to mention
earlier is
so in the middle of it um
I had a little girl born and she's she
is now nine she has been uh
she's never known me without it and
she's seen a lot and
probably had to put up with a lot as
kids do that
I don't want to say is uh bad but maybe
not typical and have you hit your kid
do you love your kid
I do yes do you scream and yell in her
face actually
if you don't mind like one of your the
First shows I ever heard from you was a
about a dad who
had left his daughter and I was
mind-boggled the whole time and I heard
your reaction and I was like yeah that's
me like I would rather I think I'd
rather die than
you split from my daughter but uh yeah I
do love her and so let me say this
definitely she's probably doing pretty
good
I hope so I do no I'm telling you right
now she's probably doing pretty good
yeah I mean there's some basic things
you can do to hurt her outside neglect
and outright physical and emotional
psychological abuse doesn't sound like
that
I can imagine you feel like you're
talking with a blanket over your head or
you're talking with tumor and you're
underwater that's depression right
right Hey listen to me she hears you and
she loves you
yeah she definitely does okay definitely
does you have an external voice that has
the stories you tell yourself so you
read that book
oh you have these stories we're born
into we have these stories that we're
told and over time those stories become
the stories we tell ourselves
yeah and depression is actually I mean
the main story is just depression
telling me that I've failed everybody
and I've failed myself and I'm not where
I should be that's right and all of that
none of that is true
none of it
and the challenge is how can I come to a
place of belief and Truth in how do I
challenge that story over time right and
continue to function in the day-to-day
you got to change the oil on this car
while you're moving right while you're
driving down the road that's tough
that's a tall order
right
have you reached the point where you're
done
you get really close to being just
exhausted
yeah it's been happening more and more
in the past like in the past years
especially where I just don't know how
to carry on okay
and I mean she's not getting any younger
either she's going to need me even more
in the future
she won't be better off with you gone
yeah and my promise if you're new to the
shows I won't lie to you
and I would tell you if you need to get
your get out of your child's life I
think I've done that before on the show
your daughter will not be better off
with young here
your daughter has a an immense ringside
seat
to a dad who's experiencing challenges
and continues to get up and do hard
things
for himself and for those he loves and
cares about which long term can be a
I I can't think of a higher gift and
honor you could hand your kid
and so far from robbing her of some
childhood that is it was a fantasy to
begin with
you're actually giving her some pretty
extraordinary opportunities
to learn and grow and see and experience
and empathize and feel
she's lucky to have you as her dad
so I stop
I hope so I don't know I'm telling you
and I don't know my own words but don't
give up on yourself
well I can tell you this this is my
belief
I think if she wasn't here
to kind of feel like a lighthouse and
the in the fog of mental illness uh
I don't know that I would be here
honestly I I don't want to think that
but there's been
some close calls we'll just say okay
have you tried
have I tried I I've luckily
called somebody before as I was on the
way to that good
do you do you promise me in front of all
these people listening and your daughter
that you will always make that call
yes
okay
can I do you know I just for your own
knowledge like
I do uh therapy regular
um I am trying to find the right
medication it's been kind of a long list
of strikeouts so there's there's another
side to that right and let's just call
it what it is that's my community right
the Mental Health Community that's
that's where I was born and raised
right right but there's a point on the
back side of a lot of counseling
in the back side of the
medication Merry-Go-Round that
everything feels like a waste of time
yes yep it almost there's almost a
compounding effect this doesn't it's not
gonna work for me foreign
right yeah absolutely
have they given you exercises
it's the l-dubs man little wins
have they walked you through that
eat well yes but I've not been very good
about uh believing it I guess if that
makes sense yeah so I heard recently and
this is it was a profound like huh
somebody was asking
um
somebody about confidence and they said
after working with a bunch of leaders
and people the most confident people I
know are people who keep their promises
to themselves
right and
I think one of the roots of depression
is I have lost the ability to trust
myself
yeah yeah absolutely
and so the step out of it
yes can be talking about it
and yes absolutely
finding the right medication if you got
major depressive disorder I'm telling
you just like if you had a heart
challenge or you had knee surgery you
needed crutches for a season
find the right medication is going to be
very important okay I have been there my
brother and they
I'm here because of it okay there's no
weakness anybody's like oh you're such
so stupid you're not
I get frustrated with my colleagues who
are medical professionals who just
Sprint to that being the first Solution
on every little discomfort that's not
where you are okay there's a difference
between I keep eating marshmallows and I
throw up and stomach cancer both of them
are right challenges with your guts one
of them takes significant intervention
the other is like hey how about you quit
eating marshmallows right so I don't
want you to beat yourself up because of
what because of the interventions you
might need to take to feel well
okay it might mean that you need to sit
down with somebody and who knows about
ketamine or you sit down with somebody
who needs to go through childhood
traumas or you need to go explore get
into medical trial for psychedelics like
there's the the treatments for like
interact irretractable uh depression
right now
um
are extraordinary they're making some
significant progress
the challenges don't give up on yourself
right
right and luckily some of those
kinds of treatments like I've followed
up on and like they've they've offered
like a sliver of Hope which is is
something so so here's the thing I want
you to practice on your own will you do
will you do this okay so I I want to
make sure that you and I are on the same
page you are committed to staying
connected with professionals both mental
health professionals and medical
professionals right okay cool right so I
think my life depends on it I would say
awesome
hey mine too
yeah okay mine too
they put me under these bright lights
and I'm sitting in front of a microphone
but mine too okay
same team
yeah
um
I want you to practice something will
you practice something
yeah of course okay
I want you to
go to Walmart or go to Walgreens or one
of these little corner stores and buy a
small little journal for like nine bucks
or ten bucks okay nothing fancy yeah
yeah and inside of it I just want you to
write
little win number one
and then I want it to be really really
small like I will have breakfast with my
daughter two times this week that's it
and here's two things are going to
happen number one
I will have breakfast I will I
I will be throwing I will have breakfast
with her
it might be that she goes out and goes
to school gets on the bus and goes to
school and I go right back to bed for
the next two hours I will have this
breakfast
yeah and
there's going to be a voice that says
what kind of freaking loser are you you
can only have it's this much of a of an
effort to have breakfast with your
daughter God she would have been better
with any other dad in the world I want
you to write that story down
right okay you have to begin to get
those stories out of your body onto a
piece of paper where you can objectively
look at it and when it takes over your
your fight or flight response system
there is no more rational thinking about
it because your body's at War
yeah okay
so when that story comes cool and then
here's the other story there's gonna be
a week that you can't make it you get up
for one and you can't do it
foreign
that's when the pit opens up and you
fall seven stories into the into the
black hole right
right
before you fall before you jump
I want you to be curious
not declare Civil War on yourself
so I want you to be curious about huh
what was my body protecting me from this
week that made that that exercise
that little win
really really hard
and if you approach your body with a
sense of curiosity instead of a sense of
Shame and you suck and Def like it's
defective and uh
there's a demo different chemical
pathway different chemical solutions to
that
makes sense it's just a posture yeah I'm
gonna quit hating Z because you know
what nobody else does dude yeah can I
ask you a hard question
absolutely have you done stupid stuff
absolutely me too
have you been really in a dark place and
thought this is it and then you woke up
and the next day the sun came out
yeah yes me too
you're not by yourself
and maybe maybe you've never heard this
you are worth being well dude
yeah and you're worth laughing and being
silly and being goofy and saying I'm
sorry because you're gonna do more
stupid stuff over the course of your
life
but most importantly you're worth not
giving up on Z
is it despair right
continue to good on the rabbit holes for
these some of these new
um
new interventions
they're very the literature out there is
very very encouraging my private
conversations with people who've gone
through them it's extraordinary right
it's really magical
okay
but you I want to make sure we got your
promise you're not giving up on you
no Nelson because if I the way I see it
is if I give up on me I'm giving up on
the people I love and I don't want to
give up on them okay but also you can't
run your life
based on other people alone at some
point you gotta look in the mirror and
say I'm so glad that I'm here
yeah those Bonkers is everything is I'm
glad that I'm here yeah
will you do one week of little wins and
then write me back and let me know that
you made it
yeah because if you do I'm gonna
celebrate with you
okay
is that cool yeah yeah I'll do it and
listen when I had both my knee surgeries
I had to learn how to walk again I
kicked too many people and got kicked
too much over the years and I had to
learn how to walk again and that meant I
had to have two professionals one either
side of me holding me up well I held
another little cane thing and we took a
step and then another step
right and I never saw two this morning
the squat workout I did and then going
for a run like I didn't think that was
ever gonna happen it is and so you're
gonna feel stupid and small and little
and less than by doing these little win
exercises
all you're doing is re-teaching your
body and brain
had a feeling how to win I not even how
to win like how to win bro no that's
what I'm talking about but like how to
engage in life Fair yeah fair enough all
right my brother hey I love you
I love you
and you've been fighting a war that most
people have no idea about you go to the
grocery store and you're at War and you
sit with your little daughter and you're
at War and you sit in the mirror and you
have War
and I want you to know you're worthy of
peace
yours peace
the light's not going out man there's
still hope
I'm glad you're with us we'll be right
back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
um
I thought
I thought Willie Nelson wrote this I
didn't know Elvis wrote this I'm sure
Elvis didn't write it either Elvis
didn't write his songs so but I believe
he had it out first
Elvis Presley's always on my mind
in honor of his daughter passed away huh
yeah Lisa Marie Presley died yesterday
that is a and a bummer man always on my
mind
maybe I didn't treat you quite as good
as I should have maybe I didn't love you
quite as often as I could have little
things I should have said and done I
just never took the time
you are always on my mind maybe I didn't
hold you all those lonely lonely times
and I guess I never told you I'm so
happy that you're mine if I made you
feel second best I'm so sorry I was
blind
you are always on my mind
see y'all soon love y'all